une fois dans la buanderie papa a poussé
ma maman mais ces retenues pape a donné
un coup de pied à maman quel téléphone
il a voulu donner un coup sur ma boîte
le téléphone c'est moi qui ai reçu
beaucoup sur nantes
[Musique]
play
le champion de vengeance
elle a pris des claques yeux des coups
de poing d'en avant
les blacks et la tête contre le matelas
vous êtes mis à califourchon sur elle
voulu arracher les cheveux
guerman les jours midi au pied ça fait
une semaine ce sont les uns sur les
autres je demande que vous soyez placé
sous contrôle judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
pour brut j'ai pu suivre la procureur de
la république sophie partouche qui
s'occupe notamment des violences
conjugales au tribunal de nancy avec la
période de confinement ces violences ont
considérablement augmenté et ce sont
majoritairement des hommes qui lui font
face dans la salle d'audience
bonjour messieurs damas
depuis le début du confinement qui a
démarré il ya maintenant à peu près six
semaines asseyez vous monsieur on repère
c'est que la plupart des affaires qui
continuent à arriver sont des affaires
de violences intrafamiliales et
précisément dans tous les cas il ya des
violences conjugales bon monsieur
il vous est reproché donc des claques
des coups de poing et puis une balayette
pour avoir projeté au sol alors j'ai lu
vos déclarations
je connais votre statut final commence à
sutton gucht rôle
[Musique]
le
ce moment
vous savez ce qu'elle dit cela dit c'est
tellement habituel
en fait elle dit mais pour moi c'est la
routine 24 mars il m'a donné deux
petites claques d'art à la tête
et puis un coup pied dans la porte
d'entrée vous fracasser la porte
d'appartement
il est venu chercher ses affaires chez
moi et là ça a dégénéré une petite
claque joue gauche
il m'a attrapée par le bras avec son
pied droit il m'a fait une balayette
pour me mettre au sol
je me suis retrouvé au sol sur mon côté
droit et qu'on est avec son genou il a
appuyé fortement sur la tombe où j'étais
coincé voilà maintenant au sol après il
m'a relevé il m'a remis à 6 sur le
tabouret ce qu'on dit de continuer sur
leur est tout simplement le code du
téléphone de coups de poing au niveau de
l'oreille d'un appel s'amusait reconnue
bien ensuite a pris une fois entre la
gorge et la poitrine
j'étais assise par terre j'ai placé mon
gros niveau de ma tête pour me protéger
il m'a bloqué mon bras entre ses jambes
m'a donné trois coups de poing à athènes
une zone
sans que je puisse me protéger
j'ai mis deux coups de poing dans la
tête mais c'était un cinq minutes j'ai
pas pris plaisir j'ai craqué quoi vous
êtes énervé comme ça sur l congrès parce
qu'elle s'occupe pas des enfants
l'enjeu donc l'enjeu on est d'accord
c'était d'abord le code du téléphone
alors monsieur compte tenu de décès je
demande que vous soyez jugé par un
tribunal correctionnel en comparution
immédiate
est-ce que je vous fait signer le procès
verbal
on ne bougeait pas j'arrive chez moi qui
me déplace
[Musique]
c'est là dessus qu'on n'est pas
complètement d'accord monsieur voyez
c'est là dessus que je peux pas vous
suivre
[Musique]
je rigole pas du tout
réfléchissez à ce que vous allez dire
devant un tribunal lundi
ça c'est les faits qui vous sont
reprochés vos déclarations le les
mentions de votre avocat
s'il ya pas de difficulté ici
il
mais
le phénomène des violences conjugales il
touche toutes les couches de la société
après bien sûr statistiquement c'est un
phénomène qu'on voit le fréquemment
alors classe moyenne des populations
précaires parquet de nancy magistrat
permanence oui bonjour aujourd'hui là
depuis quinze jours trois semaines on
voit beaucoup de personnes parfaitement
inséré il n'y a pas de problème de
d'insertion il n'y a pas de
problématique majeure stupéfiante ou
alcooliques sont des gens normaux qui
travaillent en temps normal mais qui se
retrouve tout d'un coup fourré dans une
situation pour lesquels ils ont perdu
leurs repères
voilà pour bien expliquer que alors à
des pauses clopes la fois les moulins
démarche la cogne mais vous rappeler
tout à la voilà voilà donc logiquement
effet confinement
le couple
mariés depuis 17 ans trois enfants eux
monsieur travail
dans une entreprise les coiffeurs et il
se retrouve les deux confinés sur l'âge
partiel pour lui et puis la cessation
d'activité pour elle dans son ensemble
que furent satellites sont en ce moment
son opinion way et vulgairement les gens
illégaux via ça fait vingt quatre
semaines qui sont les uns sur les autres
c'est des gens qui d'habitude se voit le
week end où se voiler soir
ça se passe plutôt pas trop mal en tout
cas il se voir comme ça et l'avouer
c'est bien plus quoi ça craque ça craque
allez c'est parti bon monsieur vous avez
fait l'objet d'une mesure de garde à vue
ensuite à une intervention des gendarmes
domicile à pour une altercation qui
s'est produite entre votre épouse et
vous même en présence des enfants
qu'est-ce qui sait pas si la ssii le
scion déclencheur les motifs de
l'altercation
il ya une suspicion de relations
adultères de votre épouse vous
concernant indique à l'ats
vous entretenez des relations
avec une tierce personne par
l'intermédiaire du téléphone c'est bien
ça andrew hélas ce jour là ça a dérapé à
cause de ça
[Musique]
oui
bougez vous devant le centre
un peu chiffonné
vous avez pris connaissance des
déclarations
on
on va pas pousser ma maman quand elle
avait des papiers en main elle voulait
pas lui donner les onze ans c'est ça je
me suis mis entre les deux en leur
demandant d'arrêter de se pousser
[Musique]
ben amor voulu avec les gendarmes n'ont
pas pas attraper le téléphone il a voulu
donner un coup sûr ma mois que le
téléphone c'est moi qui ai reçu un coup
sur la tête
c'était si important que ça alors
vous rendez compte c'est votre petit
garçon de 11 ans qui se met entre vous
et ça c'est que le début parce que ça
continue une fois dans la buanderie doit
pas pousser ma maman mais ces retenues
pape a donné un coup de pied à maman qui
est tombé dans la buanderie sur moi ma
soeur et moi avons fait appel à la
gendarmerie en faisant 17 nous avons
marqué trois fois
car papa devenait violent nous avions
peur
ces points mais
au fil du procès majoritairement est ce
si dur est déjà mature
on reçoit alors des samba tu bien sûr
les victimes de violences conjugales
sont majoritairement des femmes et en ce
sens on peut parler train de battue on
en reçoit y en a il ya des situations
d'emprise voilà et dans la plupart des
cas pour à dire les choses la domination
allait masculine mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de situations où on est dans la
zone grise
voilà et où il ya de la violence qui a
émergé il ya un passage à l'acte qui
procède là encore je le répète la
plupart du temps qui procède du membre
masculin du couple c'est à dire qu'ils
procèdent de l'homme
c'est vrai parce qu'il faille y voilà il
est là on peut pas nier mais en même
temps sur la question du passage à la
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça ça
procède des deux c'est à dire que ce qui
va passer la relation voilà c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre c'est ce qui se noue
entre les gens et très clairement le
confinement il a un effet un peu
d'effets la gratte terre qu'il ya un
effet révélateur de ces situations la
permanence accélère c'est comme ça il ya
des fois c'est hyper calme et tout d'un
coup
attention on va essayer d'aller un peu
il
bonjour messieurs dames veuillez
m'excuser un fou la petite attente alors
vous êtes impliqué à double titre
puisque vous êtes à la fois victimes de
violence que vous avez dénoncé et en
même temps mise en cause par votre
compagnon pour votre propre comportement
bon pour faire simple en fait c'est vous
qui avait dénoncé la scène de violence
qui a eu lieu alors le 26 avril au soir
et à l'occasion de sa garde à vue votre
compagnon à il en a profité pour
dénoncer votre propre agressivité il ya
essentiellement un événement en mars où
vous allez me out est devant moi j'suis
un moment donné
je me sentais extrêmement il m'est
arrivé de retoucher comme lui tous les
jours où j'allais
après sur les faits qui sont reprochés à
votre compagnon ça j'en fais mon affaire
avec lui approchez-vous faut que
j'arrête avec ça mettez-vous là monsieur
on vous reproche quand même
des violences sur votre
conjointe sur votre balle sur le fils de
celle ci
parce que banal dis donc premières
réactions violentes donc ça c'était dans
la chambre avait claqué la tête contre
le matelas vous avez bien que les foules
censure elle voulu arracher les cheveux
je lui avais mis un coup au visage
tous les deux séparément même fait le
constat que la relation est terminée
vous confirmer que de votre côté
ce diagnostic là j'ai fait le choix pour
l'instant on l'état de ne pas vous
poursuivre devant le tribunal
à condition vous soumettiez un certain
nombre de mesures
je demande que vous accomplissiez à vos
frais je pense pas que ce soit un
obstacle que vous participiez à un stage
de prévention des violences conjugales
et de responsabilisation des auteurs de
violences conjugales
et puis je demande est là encore c'est
important
pendant les trois mois qui viennent donc
jusque fin juillet que vous résidiez
hors du domicile conjugal
les outils qu'on a on les avait déjà
avant en clair la participation à un
stage de prévention à de
responsabilisation des auteurs de
violences conjugales c'est un outil qui
aujourd'hui classique en tout cas à
nancy et qui est parfaitement adapté
pour ces situations là ces stages pour
conjoints violents dont parle la
procureure on a pu en film et à quelques
mois avant le confinement ça se passe
dès le premier acte de violence avec
l'espoir de mettre un terme le plus tôt
possible aux brutalités
vous allez le voir certains d'entre eux
n'ont pas encore conscience de la
gravité de leur acte et pratiquement
tous ont eux mêmes été victimes de
violences dans leur enfance
or ici
sac rose à quelqu'un ça depuis
l'humiliation
vous l'avez connu le ceinturant le
martinez à vis de la chose
ce glissement c'était c'est mal fait par
exemple avec ce jeu avec ses chevaliers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre histoire
l'adulte
c'est aussi quelque chose qui vienne
parce que sous
pour la plupart d'entre vous c'est sur
ma décision ou la décision d'un mes
collègues que vous êtes là je suis
procureur n'y aura pas deux sages qui
nous rendra deux d'accord
juridiquement on n'est pas du tout
d'accord ça va des violences réciproques
et encore c'est pas parce rouveau une
vive que vous avez de rendre mes quatre
chiffres
c'est bien déjà de la reconnaître c'est
ce qui se passe c'est que la justice est
intéressant si vous vous retrouver de
nouveau en situation d'agression
qu'est ce que vous faites je crois
toujours mais ça fait partie des
solutions
l'idée c'est pas de but en blanc
d'adhérer mais en vous demande
simplement suffisamment ouverts pendant
la journée pour qu'au terme de la
journée peut-être peut-être vous
puissiez vous dire vous soyez un petit
peu moins assurée à vous dire que c'est
pas vous que vous n'avez pas grand chose
à vous reprocher et que peut-être il ya
des choses à travailler
l idée c vous repartiez ce soir avec des
outils et avec way une prise de
conscience j'ai poussé par ses employés
par le mage nuit d'orage h et son besoin
alors effectivement aller voir dans mon
appartement
personne
c
c'est pas qu'est ce qu'elle peut sceller
ce qu'est ce qu'il faut qu'elle fasse il
faut dénoncer les faits sans quoi nous
ne peut rien faire évidemment faut faire
sortir la situation extérieure et il
faut savoir que les solutions qui
existent concrètement derrière c'est
l'éloignement du conjoint qui est
toujours possible on exfiltre pas madame
et les enfants ça c'est le paradigme 10
à 30 ans donc il n'y a pas d'obstacle à
ce que l'on mette fin dans les meilleurs
délais les meilleurs délais ces dans les
24 heures on met fin immédiatement à la
situation dangereuse pour les personnes
si vous êtes en danger vous pouvez
porter plainte au commissariat ou à la
gendarmerie la plus proche
mais vous pouvez aussi appeler le 39 19
un numéro vert pour toutes les victimes
de violences conjugales
[Musique]